today on the matt walsh show children's
hospitals around the country are
butchering mutilating and sterilizing
their young patients new videos reveal
just how widespread and depraved this
practice is and that brings us to an
important question
what are we going to do about it i have
some ideas also more information is
released about the fbi's fishing
expedition at mar-a-lago and cbs has
figured out why kids these days are fat
it's because of climate change of course
in our daily cancellation camel harris
tries to explain the concept of equity
it doesn't go well but in fairness to
her there is no coherent way to explain
equity all of that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
roe v wade has been overturned and this
battle is now finally leaving dc and
going to the grassroots no group in
america is better positioned than 40
days for life with about a million
volunteers in a thousand cities 40 days
for life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities they have a larger
presence in blue states with california
being their largest state which is where
they're needed the most so that's very
good news some former abortion facility
directors say these vigils can cause the
abortion no-show rate to go as high as
75
which is detrimental to their abortion
business to say the least these
law-abiding vigils have closed many
abortion businesses in america and
nearly half of these closed um were in
liberal cities where abortions will
remain legal including closures in san
francisco chicago and seattle 40 days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and minds on the grassroots to end
abortion check out their locations and
podcasts and free magazine at
40daysforlife.com
now is not the time for us to back down
or think that the the fight is over
to protect life in so many ways it
really now just begins at the very least
it enters a new and very important phase
and that's why we need 40 days for life
so for more information on 40 days for
life go to 40daysforlife.com
welcome back to the matt wall show i
have survived barely my harrowing bout
with laryngitis and it has cleared up
just in time because there's a lot to
talk about
more importantly there's a lot to do we
are way past the stage where anything
can be fixed by simply talking about it
the rot in this house is too deep too
pervasive we've ignored it for too long
and now we have only two choices left we
can continue to paint over the problem
put it out of sight and out of mind
until the floor gives out and the roof
caves in and we're all buried or we can
get to work on some real repairs take
out the sledge hammers crowbars start
pulling the rotting pieces out and
replacing them with better material
now the latter strategy will be
difficult there's no guarantee that we
can salvage what's been neglected for so
long but it gives us a chance at least
it's much better than sitting around
waiting for the ceiling to fall on us
especially because this dilapidated old
shack that we're living in
is increasingly unsafe for our children
so late last week a video went viral
from boston children's hospital
advertising what they described as
gender affirming hysterectomies in fact
bch has or had anyway dozens of videos
on their website and youtube channel
promoting all manner of barbarism and
mutilation for minors for obvious
reasons uh this one especially caught
people's eyes if you haven't seen it
what yeah let's uh let's watch
gender firming hysterectomy is very
similar to most hysterectomies that
occur
hysterectomy itself is the removal of
the uterus the cervix which is the
opening of the uterus and the fallopian
tubes which are attached to the sides of
the uterus some gender affirming
hysterectomies will also include the
removal of the ovaries but that's
technically a separate procedure called
a bilateral oophrectomy and not every
gender forming hysterectomy includes
that and people who are getting gender
forming hysterectomies do not have to
have their ovaries removed
yes a gender affirming hysterectomy is
similar to other forms of hysterectomies
in the same way that having your leg
eaten off by a shark is similar to
having it amputated because of gangrene
you know they're similar only in the
comparative end result of no longer
having that body part attached to you
but the similarities end there because
in one
you're getting a necessary and
life-saving medical procedure and in the
other you're being mauled by a savage
beast
whether that beast is a shark or a
smiley polite gender affirmation surgeon
it's the same
you know naturally our brave media fact
checkers were on the case as soon as
that video went viral a few days later a
series of fact checks were posted
assuring the public that in fact these
hysterectomies are they're not performed
on minors at all they're not don't worry
they assure us that's not happening
doctors wait until a girl is 18. three
years before she can legally buy her own
wine cooler
seven years before she can rent her own
car before they um begin removing her
reproductive organs
that's a good thing because it's not
like 18 year olds are notorious for
making rash and self-destructive
decisions that they'll regret later in
life right i mean 18 year olds are
perfectly equipped to make any decision
imaginable
but of course the fact checks are also
wrong
as a reporter for the post-millennial
christina buttons points out boston
children's hospital follows wpath
guidelines and wpath recommends
hysterectomies and genital surgeries for
17 year olds and double mastectomies for
15 year olds also she notes bch will
perform a phalloplasty which is the
creation of a fake penis using the
severed skin from the forearm at the age
of 18 but hysterectomies have to be
completed three months before that
which means that they could be done at
17.
but this all really amounts to hair
splitting whether gender affirming
hysterectomies are performed on girls
when they're 17 and a half or six months
later the horror and atrocity
is that they're being performed at all
and while the trans cult tries to
confuse the conversation by quibbling
over the exact age in which these
various brands of butchery are inflicted
on young people the incontrovertible
fact remains that girls as young as 13
are having their breasts chopped off
and both boys and girls as young as 16
if not younger are undergoing
irreversible forms of genital mutilation
and even before any of that prepubescent
children are being castrated and
sterilized and this is happening in
every state and in hospital hundreds of
hospitals and other establishments
across the entire country
like the children's hospital of
pittsburgh for example which also went
viral a few days ago for its own video
promoting this particular type of child
abuse listen
hi my name is priya dar i'm one of the
doctors at the center for adolescent and
young adult health here at the
children's hospital of pittsburgh i
wanted to talk to you guys today a
little bit about puberty blockers
puberty blockers are basically a
medication that says hey let's just put
a pause on puberty and that can be
really beneficial for younger kids who
have start already started the puberty
process who either might go through a
lot of psychological distress as they go
through puberty if they're struggling
with gender dysphoria or for somebody
who's saying hey i'm not really sure if
i feel comfortable in my body or or what
gender i truly identify with
they aren't comfortable in their bodies
and so doctors will irreversibly damage
their bodies in order to ensure that
they will never be comfortable in their
bodies that's the general strategy with
puberty blockers this is also why the
claims that surgeries are held until 18
are not only objectively and wildly
false it's just not true but they're
also irrelevant because no matter when
the surgeries are performed the stage is
set physically and medically
before these children even hit puberty
they're put on the conveyor belt held
heading towards the meat grinder and
most will stay on
until they're fed right into it
that's how this is all designed
indeed they're put on the assembly line
well before the onset of puberty
years before
another boston children's hospital video
promotes the idea that children
can identify themselves as trans
from the minute they're born
listen
so most of the patients that we have in
the gems clinic actually know their
gender usually around the age of puberty
but a good portion of children do know
as early as seemingly from the womb and
they will usually express their gender
identity as very young children some as
soon as they can talk they might say
phrases such as i'm a girl or i'm a boy
or i'm going to be a woman or i'm going
to be a mom kids know very very early so
in the gems clinic we see a variety of
young children all the way down to ages
two and three and usually up to the ages
of nine when they come into the clinic
they'll see one of our psychologists and
we'll be talking to them about their
gender we'll be talking to their family
about how to best support that child and
how to make sure that that child has the
space and support to explore their
gender and do well throughout their
development and we'll be answering any
parent questions a lot of parents do
have questions and so we answer those
questions the biggest piece of advice i
give parents who are coming through the
gender clinic at boston children's
hospital is to just be supportive
sometimes you might not understand
sometimes you feel like you don't know
the terms or you don't
get exactly what the child means when
they say that they might be this gender
but the biggest thing you can do is just
love your child and support them and
just allow them to express themselves
that's the biggest protector as well
against negative mental health effects
such as depression suicidality anxiety
that we worry about for our gender
diverse kids and young adults so that
support from a parent is one of the best
protective factors and one of the best
things they can do
from the womb
you know children uh babies just out of
the womb
don't even
recognize they don't have a concept of
their own selves they have no selfhood
they don't they don't recognize
themselves
as being distinct entities apart from
their mothers they they see them and
their mothers as being one in the same
so uh but a child with no concept of
self
can yet have a concept of gender
how do we know this well because uh they
might refuse to get a haircut when
they're toddlers or they're peeing the
wrong way or they're trying on a
sibling's clothing
or they're playing with opposite gender
toys she says
so according to boston children's
hospital literally every toddler who has
ever been born or will ever be born is
trans
because that describes the behavior of
all toddlers everywhere for all time
now if it seems like they're casting the
widest imaginable net in order to catch
the most children they can and put them
all in a path to sterilization and
butchery before they can even talk
well that's because that's exactly what
these monsters are doing
they're doing it with full knowledge of
what they're doing and why and they've
done it up until this moment without
much resistance from the public
but that has to end
we have to stop making it so easy on
them
and that's why i'm in the very early
stages of trying to organize a national
coordinated effort
to fight back against this evil
it is to our shame that there aren't
rallies and vigils outside of every
hospital every clinic where kids are
being butchered and sterilized
it is an indictment on our entire
culture and everyone in it that there
has not been mass marches on washington
with hundreds of thousands of people
speaking out against this
there should be a full-scale assault
encompassing activism lawsuits political
action
we should be pressing every pressure
point all at once
now so far there has been resistance but
it's been haphazard localized
disconnected usually quite small in
scale
i want to change that
i can't do it on my own obviously that's
the point nobody can
but i can use my platform and resources
that i have to mobilize an overwhelming
national effort to save our kids from
this madness and that's what i'm going
to try to do
you know it's really just a matter of
where do we begin
maybe we begin at boston children's
hospital
maybe we begin with thousands and
thousands of people outside of that
building
we'll have to figure it out
and i do expect that um
if we really ramp up our efforts to
fight back against this things will get
ugly they already have
for me personally they have this weekend
trans activists on twitter developed a
new strategy for coming after me um
personally they they decided to start
tweeting that i'm a child abuser now
there's of course no basis at all for
this charge it's not grounded in
anything whatsoever they simply invented
it out of whole cloth knowing that
defamatory claims if they take on a life
of their own and are filtered through
mostly anonymous accounts that would be
difficult to sue for defamation can be
as harmful as they are baseless
now they have no moral standards they
have no capacity for shame or guilt
and so there's no lie they won't tell
there's no libel they'll shy away from
this is certainly not the first time
that these people have tried to mass you
know have tried mass defamation against
me as a strategy since my film came out
in june since before that really but
especially since the film
i've been constantly slandered and
defamed on top of that they've tried to
get me kicked off of every platform
through one mass reporting effort after
another
i've been doxxed they've threatened to
kill me many times
things have happened that i can't even
talk about for security reasons but
suffice it to say that the threats have
made it close to home
but as far as i'm concerned these are
all prices worth paying in fact
every bit of slander every death threat
every dirty trick from these people only
radicalizes me even more
if if the backlash has caused me to
reflect on anything
it's only made me reflect on why i'm not
doing even more to oppose these people
so after that sort of reflection and
reconsideration
i've decided to double down triple down
i've decided to be even more radical and
extreme in the fight against this
scourge
i've decided to keep doing
everything they don't want me to do and
saying everything they don't want me to
say except i'll do it more and say it
louder
and i'll be a bigger pain in the ass
than i've ever been
and i would ask everyone else to make
the same pledge
because we can't sit around waiting for
things to improve anymore
i mean this has to stop it just has to
and we have to make it stop
starting now
let's get to our five headlines
what if there was um someone out there
who kept a log of every single thing you
did every minute of the day i think that
would be pretty creepy but what if i
told you that's exactly what happens
every time you go online your internet
provider is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited they
can legally sell this data to anyone
they want that's why i always use
expressvpn expressvpn reroute your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your internet provider can't
see or log anything you're doing online
uh now many of you might be wondering
well if i'm routing all my data through
a vpn then doesn't the vpn uh have
access to all that and can they log the
data well you're right to think that
because many vpns claim to have a no
logs policy but they've been caught
logging customer activity anyway except
expressvpn is the only vpn i trust
because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major vpn
provider to engineer all of their vpn
servers to run in ram this makes it
impossible for their vpn servers to
store any data including logs of any
express expressvpn customer you don't
have to take my or expressvpn's word for
it expressvpn is so confident in their
no logs claim that they have had one of
the biggest assurance firms pwc audit
their technology and uh that's how you
know it's no wonder that the verge named
expressvpn the number one vpn in the
entire world stop letting people keep
logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com walsh right now find out
how you can get three months free that's
expressvpn.comvpn.comwalsh go to
expressvpn.com
walsh right now to learn more
you know when i uh first came down with
the gitis laryngitis i um actually
thought it would be not so bad at first
but kind of a nice break
i don't have to talk you know but i
quickly discovered that not having a
voice really makes you an invalid
whether you like it or not especially in
a house with four little kids
you know my my loud sort of a booming
man voice really comes in handy when a
company was hurting the cats at home but
i don't have that it just it's um
it's really difficult so if i all week
if i needed to stop the kids from doing
something or tell them to do something i
had to like wave and flap my arms around
and use improvised sign language
and even if they knew what i was saying
they would act like they didn't and i
knew what game they were playing so my
son would be like literally climbing the
wall and i'd start flailing around hey
and he would just look at me and go what
daddy i can't i can't hear you i'm sorry
i can't
i will come closer to hear you but i'm
climbing the wall right now and i don't
know what you're telling me so sorry
daddy
these are the ways that you're taking
advantage of uh hopefully my my voice
holds up though at least for for one
show anyway
um because i want to start with this
this was a story that we were tracking
last week we talked about last week for
the one show where i could talk
um eli ehrlich is a trans activist an
influencer who it was revealed by libs
of tick tock posted on instagram a few
months ago announcing a plan to send
prescription hormone pills to anyone who
wants them across the country including
miners
in circumvention of state states that
are outlawing uh these drugs for kids
also in circumvention of like every law
of every federal law i mean you can't
you can't just take prescription pills
and mail them to somebody um much less
can you organize a distribution network
for the illegal
uh distribution and dealing of
prescription drugs which is what eli
earlier confessed to doing
and um
and it turned out that ehrlich had
talked about this plan many times before
we played the youtube video with a sort
of a confession which has now been
deleted there were other instagram posts
as well then there and then there were
these um
other twitter posts which libs of tick
tock dug up a couple of days ago
just to show you how often ehrlich has
talked about this this is on twitter
this is in violation of twitter's rules
by the way of course like you're not
allowed on any of these platforms
according to their rules you cannot use
their platforms to facilitate the
commission of a crime
and so erlich posted in may says as i've
said before if anyone needs hormones who
can't get access message me i have a
network with years of extra doses this
is only a band-aid solution to an
ongoing political problem but we can't
rely on the state or medical
institutions to keep us safe and healthy
update we now have a full network of
trans people with prescriptions for
testosterone shots and testo gel too we
refused to let texas prevent trans youth
from accessing care that was in february
in also february after reading about the
sickening new texas directive against
trans youth i will personally mail
estradiol uh and uh spirano lactone to
anyone worried about the government
coming after your kids f you greg abbott
okay so this is
in testosterone by the way a schedule 3
controlled substance
but it's being announced on twitter on
youtube on instagram
this illegal drug distribution thing
plan
now i recommended last week reporting
this to the dea and if you haven't done
that yet then uh now i know it's the dea
the
the chances that they'll do anything are
relatively slim you should report it
anyway and if you haven't yet go to go
to the da's website it's very easy to go
google it find the tip line and um
and
send the tip in
um
ehrlich also lives i believe in new york
city so if you want to contact local law
enforcement if you haven't done that yet
i know a lot of people have you can
contact local law enforcement let them
know they have a confessed drug dealer
running this prescription drug ring in
the city maybe they should want to do
something about that i also mentioned
that ehrlich is a phd candidate at um
university of california santa cruz now
i said last week that i'd give the
leadership there a day to respond and to
tell us what steps they would take to
address this before i started giving out
their contact information well they
never did address it and i was out for a
week
so they actually ended up getting a week
and now it's time to escalate
um university of california santa cruz
is a public university
these
officials have no right
to ignore this issue
they just don't have the right to do it
you can't ignore it
okay you're a public institution there's
a confessed drug dealer sending drugs to
kids
at your school you can't just ignore the
public when we're concerned about it
um
they have to tell us what they're going
to do so here's what we're going to do
first of all i want to put up on the
screen we have a an organizational flow
chart for uc santa cruz i want you to
take a look at that maybe take a
screenshot of it or something
these are and you see some email
addresses there as well but there you
see uh all of the the whole leadership
at uc santa cruz you see all their names
there
and these are all people that we should
be reaching out to to ask what are they
going to do about this
a phd candidate has confessed
to a highly illegal
prescription drug distribution ring
targeting miners what are you going to
do about it is the question
but we should start i think
with
the chancellor of the university who is
cynthia larive
and we'll put her uh contact information
up there now you can email her
chancellor
ucsc.edu you can call her
two nine 831-459-4291 i would start with
her i mean she's at the top of the
hierarchy she's the leader so she should
be the first one we contact
there's also peter beale who has his
pronouns of course listed on his on his
uh
profile on the site he's the vice
provost and the dean of graduate studies
so this is a phd candidate also a good
person to contact 831-459-3336
or pbl biehl
ucsc.edu
so i want you to call and email these
two officials at the university and ask
them what they are doing to con to
investigate the confessed drug dealer at
the university confessed felon
if they continue to ignore us next i
will find the board of trustees and i
will find the donors at the school
and we're going to start reaching out to
them
and after that
if we still don't get a response then
we're going to show up there with a
crowd of people
i'll come there personally because you
cannot ignore us
that is not an option
if this was anybody else
if this was not a trans person if this
wasn't hormone prescription pills but
some other prescription being
distributed
as part of this illegal drug dealing
ring
um
we all know the university would have
kicked this person out of the school by
now
instead they want to give them
you know instead it's it's uh it's well
we're gonna we're gonna give all not
even benefit of the doubt it's just all
the
it's it's a it is a get out of jail free
card literally
but that's not going to be acceptable
so again what are you going to do about
a university you have to tell us
i will not allow you to ignore us you
cannot it is not an option
all right
let's move to this
daily beast
says former president donald trump is
under investigation for several
violations of the espionage act and
illegally keeping top secret government
documents when he left the white house
last year according to court documents
unsealed friday afternoon
and the fbi was spurred to move so
aggressively and search the former
president mar-a-lago ocean side of state
in florida because some of the documents
they were seeking pertain to the
nation's nuclear weapons
uh this is of course by the way this is
not this is this is the first time right
that uh
that the intelligence community has told
us stories about things related to
nuclear weapons in order to justify some
outrageous activity that they're
engaging in this has never happened
before
right
i mean i might be able to think of one
or two other times maybe
it's hard to remember that was so long
ago the fbi search warrant lists three
federal statutes to justify the search
of the palm beam palm beach mansion
that means the justice department in
historic move is investigating the
former president for violating the
espionage act mishandling federal
records and falsifying official
documents to obstruct an investigation
now
the espionage act totally absurd to use
on on president trump
um and trump has
repeatedly stated
that he declassified all these documents
before bringing them to his house
which is something that he is able to do
i mean he that's that's what you're able
to do as as a president you can just
like
wave your hand essentially over a box of
documents and say
this is declassified
it is pretty much that easy you can
declassify anything you want as a
present
so this was obviously a trolling attempt
and not trolling in the sense of my
favorite pastime but trolling as in the
fishing technique which is i guess my
second favorite pastime this is just
throwing some lines in the water
drifting across the lake
and uh hoping you get a bite
that's all this is
now
you know there's
a lot of people making predictions about
where this goes from here a lot of uh
you hear a lot of conservatives saying
well trump's going to get frog marched
he's they're going to put him in cuffs
they're going to you know and and maybe
they will do all of that
but they also have to know
obviously
that through this
action they have boosted trump's 2024
chances considerably and especially in
the primaries
now how much they're gonna help him in
the general i'm not sure but the fact
that they've helped him in the primaries
to put him you know he was already at
the top of the heap among republican uh
challengers
but to
make that divide even wider i mean
they've done quite a bit there
if they were to put president trump in
handcuffs
and have that image out there
well then that would just
that would uh
all the more solidify if he wasn't
already solidified as the almost certain
nominee in 2024
which does make you wonder about
conspiracy theories
and i've heard others
asking this question like
did they do this
to intentionally boost trump and drown
out desantis
we've been we've been hearing
the drum beat for a long time and there
was even there was someone today who
posted it again some uh
lib blue check i don't remember who who
said you know desantis is he's even more
dangerous than trump
he's even more dangerous
and that's what they really believe they
believe that desantis is a greater
danger to their agenda
than donald trump is i think they're
probably right i think i think they're
right in that assumption
so all i'm saying is that
if they wanted to make sure that trump
is not the nominee and not desantis
what they did last week would be the
there'd be no better plan than that
that's like the best possible thing they
could have done to ensure that trump is
a nominee and not desantis
so that's the conspiracy theory did they
do this intentionally to boost trump and
drown out desantis
and also put desantis in a position
where he feels like he has to support
trump for president rather than running
himself
you know it's not a crazy theory the
only reason that i don't uh i i
understand why people have theorized
about it the only reason i don't
subscribe to it is that
and maybe maybe i underestimate them to
my own detriment but i don't think the
regime is smart enough to play chess on
that level
from everything i've seen they're not
quite smart enough for that
because that would actually be a
brilliant chess move i'm not sure if
they're that smart
i think it's uh it's more likely that
they are just
they can't help themselves i mean this
has been the story with the left
and the left's approach to trump
ever since he showed up on the scene
they cannot help themselves
every all of the freak outs all the
panicking
um the way they constantly talk about
them keep them in the headlines it only
helps him and but they can't help it
because they hate him so much
and they're so emotional that they can't
control themselves
now we also have to keep in mind too
that we're talking about um
bureaucracies you know we're talking
about the government and so they're
going to be a lot of different
motivations playing into this
so maybe at some level somewhere there
are some people pulling the strings uh
with with some more intention behind it
i don't know
all right cbs news has noticed that kids
today are fat
and uh i think we've all probably noted
that
and they've found the culprit
it's not what you think
or maybe it is if you think just like
these people
god pity you uh let's listen
there's a new study showing how climate
change specifically higher temperatures
is making our children uh more inactive
and more obese the study published in a
journal temperature found today's
children are 30 percent less aerobically
fit than their parents were at their age
fewer children are reaching the world
health organization's recommendation of
60 minutes of exercise a day now listen
it has been a lot harder hotter and the
weather has been crazy but i think it
also has to do with technology you know
yeah it's one thing not to go outside
but these kids don't go outside because
they can stay inside and be on their
phones play video games and be social
without having to go outside and be
social
okay well it's not a lot hotter first of
all according to the government's own
climate change website climate.gov you
can go there
temperatures have risen two degrees
fahrenheit
since pre-industrial times so that's if
we're going with their data and we're
just going to accept it on face value
then 2 degrees
in 150
years
according to this information we're
about a half a degree hotter maybe
than we were when i was a kid in the 90s
and this counts as a lot hotter
it explains why kids don't go outside
turn the temperature down by half a
degree and it changes or turn it up
rather by having and it changes
everything
really but but what about the seasons
so every time these people talk about
climate change they just ignore the
concept of seasons
i mean the temperature does drop by a
lot more than half a degree for kids
today um because it's not summer
temperatures all year long unless you
live on the equator
so do kids suddenly go outside and play
in the fall in the spring
in the in the winter in the early summer
no they don't
also by the way you can look at obesity
rates by state
and there is no correlation between
average temperature and obesity west
virginia is one of the fattest states
with a but it's got a mean annual
temperature of 56 degrees west virginia
but it's a beautiful
the the temperature is at least by my
for my taste the temperature is always
almost always great it's a beautiful
place a beautiful state to to go and run
around outside and yet
it's it's the second fattest state in
the country
florida is on average 20 degrees or more
hotter and yet it's one of the skinniest
states
and this becomes um
even more you know this lack of
correlation becomes even more apparent
when you look at it on a global scale
okay because there are a great many very
hot
tropical
you know climates
where people are not only not obese but
oftentimes famished starving
you know their ribs are poking out of
their bodies
and why is that well because this is
about food
okay obesity is about food it's about
the foods you put in your body
it's how many how much how many calories
you put in your body
versus how many you burn
that's where obesity comes from that's
it
that is the whole story of obesity
if you are obese it is because
you are
taking in a lot more calories than
you're burning
end of discussion
and that's why in third world countries
um they don't seem to have the fat gene
surprisingly
why is that because they're not eating
enough
and if you don't eat enough then instead
of being overweight you're going to be
very much underweight
so why are kids fat
um i mean it is an important question
it is something we should be talking
about
but they're fat because they're eating
garbage food
and they're sitting around on their
phones all day
we hear the cbs guy at the end he makes
mention of that well i think it has
something to do with technology too
that's not just something to do with
technology
that's the whole that that along with
with the food that's that's that's the
whole story 50 50 right there
the food is bad
and kids are sitting around on their
phones all day
doesn't matter how beautiful the
temperature is outside
and it's even worse like it's
yeah this is this is being we've gone
way beyond mere laziness or anything
like that
kids many kids today
no longer have
just the innate desire
to go run around
outside okay and that and that should be
innate
now i know for my own kids we don't give
them phones we don't do technology um we
don't they we have a tv we don't let
them watch it that much though
and and my kids can certainly be lazy
don't get me wrong about that
but they still have this youthful
natural energy where they just
they want to be outside i mean i i hear
all that well it's too hot for kids to
go outside we live in tennessee
it's like six thousand degrees here all
the time with a humidity of six thousand
percent and my kids will go running
around outside
we have to tell them to come in so they
don't get heat exhaustion
and that's normal for kids
that doesn't make my kids special quite
the opposite just makes them normal kids
but for a lot of kids they they they've
become so numb so sort of dead to the
world
that they don't even have the desire to
run outside and explore
and go into the woods and just whatever
kids do you know we we all tell the
stories about when we were kids and you
go out and you know you go out at seven
o'clock in the morning you come back you
wouldn't be back until dinner
well that's not just a get off my lawn
you know back in my day kind of rant
it is an observation
about a wide sweeping social change that
has happened in this culture and it is a
it is a
a horrible change
and we we still
really cannot
conceive of what this is going to be
like in the future
to have a generation of kids raised on
this stuff raised on screens utterly
dependent on them
from
toddler on
um what does that look like
what kind of world are we living in in
40 years for years i mean certainly it's
going to be a fat world even fatter than
it is now
but in a lot of ways that's like the
least of our problems
all right so this is kind of um
old news but i've had it earmarked for
over a week and i have to say something
about it
it's the kind of thing i just have to
comment on
so all right we know that espn sports
commentators have an average iq
somewhere slightly below like a hermit
crab
though perhaps slightly above an oyster
i'll give them that i'm not totally
convinced on the latter point i mean
they are very dumb is the point they're
also left-wing hacks um yet the most
important thing that i'm always
reminding people about the sports
commentators is that
they are with rare exception embarrassed
to be sports commentators
there's nothing at all
ignoble or shameful about the profession
in and of itself we have sports
commentators here at the daily wire
craning company very talented
intelligent put together a really good
show there's nothing wrong with with
talking about sports and and that's your
job but the espn brand of sports
analysts they take a different approach
they apparently find their vocation to
be lacking in importance
and so their egos and delusions of
grandeur lead them to conclude that they
can't simply talk about sports and leave
it at that they have to they have to
have important things to say right they
have to start conversations
they have to be thought leaders
and it's it's just a problem to be a
thought leader when you don't have any
thoughts
and so they attempt to be culturally and
politically relevant in ways that strain
their poor tiny brains and lead to
extremely embarrassing episodes like
this from former nba player uh turned
mba commentator jalen rose he took to
social media a little while ago it was a
week or two ago
to offer his thoughts on the history of
mount rushmore now if you at any point
in your life
have wondered about jalen rose's
opinions vis-a-vis rushmore well um here
you go
why do you think
washington changed their name
from redskins
i do a show and didn't say that word for
eight years
and my co-host david jacoby we both said
they're gonna change the name one day
why
because it's offensive
what about the cleveland indians same
thing why did they change the name
because it's offensive
so i want to
continue
to challenge myself and to challenge you
to do something can we retire using
mount rushmore
that should be offensive to all of us
especially native americans the
indigenous people who are the first
people here before christopher columbus
that land was stolen for them
when it was discovered that it contained
gold
and 25 years later
to add insult to injury
four american presidents
were put on what we call mount
rushmore on the top
of the dead bodies
that is buried
right underneath
so i call for you and for myself i'm
owning this too
let's stop using the term mount rushmore
when we talk about our favorite rappers
talking about our favorite movies we
talking about our favorite players i
know you're going to see this video and
i know you're going to take action
um no i'm not i'm not going to take any
action at all
this guy's had at the beach beautiful
day and he's sitting there thinking
about why he's offended by mount
rushmore
what kind of
what kind of mind works that way
and of course needless to say this might
make it onto the mount rushmore of
stupid opinions but let's back it up he
begins by asking
why the redskins changed their name he
says it's because the name is offensive
now there was a time when a jock right a
former athlete would rather drown
himself in the nearest river than
publicly admit to getting their feelings
hurt by a sports mascot
just talk about changes through time
to be a an athlete talk about well it's
an offensive mascot
you know there was there was there was a
time when no no no man at all but
certainly no athlete would speak that
way he then claims that the cleveland
indians is also an offensive name yet he
like every other member of the pc
brigade can't begin to explain why
if the term indian is so insulting
then why do the indians themselves use
it
in fact i went to the national congress
of american indians website
the national congress of american
indians indians website that's it and
found literally dozens of tribal
organizations that all have the word
indian in their needs
dozens
of actual groups of indians calling
themselves indians
why is it offensive
then he of course he moves on to the
topic at hand talking about mount
rushmore why it's offensive
um he says it's uh you know hurtful and
traumatizing to the indigenous people
who rose says were were there first and
you know had their lands stolen and then
and then faced the added indignity of
having four presidents carved into the
mountain right over top the dead bodies
now as that last claim i can tell you
that mount rushmore
is carved into granite so i highly doubt
that there were grave sites desecrated
i don't think they were burying people
in granite that would seem like a rather
uh
it's an impractical way of disposing of
bodies to to bury them inside a granite
rock face
but did we steal the land as rose claims
no the black hills
where the monument is located
have changed hands many times over the
centuries
the lakota most recently had it
before the americans had it
before them it was the cheyenne before
then it was another tribe on down
through the years
different groups of people fighting and
killing over that piece of land
the quote indigenous people were not a
monolith they were not homogeneous they
were not a united people or culture or
nation it doesn't even make any sense to
talk about them in that way that's not
how they saw themselves it's not that's
not the rea they all just happened to
live on this continent
and they were fighting and killing each
other over the land for thousands of
years
they were warring factions who
slaughtered each other mercilessly
the americans couldn't steal the black
hills from the lakota for the same
reason that you know you couldn't be
accused of stealing a car from a thief
who just stole it from somebody else
right i mean really to imagine you had a
car
that is just just perpetually stolen so
often that we don't even know who had it
first now
well there might be someone who's the
victim we don't even know who that
person is
but if you run up and take it from the
person who most recently stole it
they can't claim that they what are they
gonna go to the police
and say well he stole the thing i stole
that's essentially what's happening
there's another point too this is why
this sort of thing really annoys me
is that we have this guy jalen rose
plays a game for a living
flippantly sort of dismissing the
careers and contributions of theodore
roosevelt abraham lincoln george
washington and thomas jefferson
he's offended by their presence on the
monument
each of those men
in any random six month period of their
adult lives
accomplished more and had a greater and
more positive impact on the world than
jalen rose has ever had or ever will
have
jalen rose could live 50 lifetimes
and not achieve what one of those men
did in six months
that's how significant they were
they deserve to be on the mountain when
you have a life like that
and you contribute to that extent
to
civilization
then yeah you deserve to the monument
you deserve to be on the mountain
and they deserve it more than any indian
tribal chief as they all contributed far
more to the society we currently live in
and they help to build our civilization
in a way that no tribal leader ever did
which isn't much of a knock on tribal
leaders i mean it's a high bar to clear
admittedly
they all have had a greater impact on
the world than i have ever had or ever
will have also
okay so i'm admitting that this is a bar
that's really hard for anyone to get
over
so it's not really an insult when i say
well you don't stack up to these guys
almost nobody does
but that's but that's why none of us end
up on the sides of mountains
that is reserved for the greatest
and when we say great we don't mean
perfect we don't mean saints
we mean great in terms of the
contribution
like there's a reason we still talk
about them to to to live and die
and a hundred years eight or later 150
years later 200 years later people are
still talking about you and learning
about you
that means that you
lived in a way that was just that that
far surpasses
most people
most of us will live and die and nobody
will ever talk about us once our once
our immediate family has gone along with
us and they go to the grave no one will
ever say our names ever again it's it's
a really startling and depressing thing
to think about but it's true
for the vast majority we will die
and then our families will die and our
names will never be uttered again
on earth
so that's most people that's like 99.99
of all people
and you stack it up against the people
that have the monuments and they get the
cities and everything named after them
um that's because of the greatness of
those people
and we should admire greatness rather
than being offended by it
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
regardless of what the administration
defines as a recession americans are
certainly worried food and gas prices
are higher than i've ever seen in my
lifetime which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers a
recession-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe imagine if car companies did
this like what if you uh could have
bought your 2020 ford at 1990s pricing
that's what good ranchers does for its
customers not only that but good
ranchers is also currently running a
back to school give back program with
the goal of donating 100 000 high
quality meals this month to children in
need so go to
goodranchers.com walsh use code walsh at
checkout they'll get 30 off plus free
shipping you can um subscribe to lock in
your price and recession proof your
meals for life
and you can help these guys reach their
goal of donating 100 000 meals to
children who may need it going into the
fall semester that's
goodranchers.comwalsh and use codewalsh
at checkout
well we only had one show last week as
you know our most recent video was
something we posted on thursday when i
was still besieged by laryngitis
heroically i came to work i recorded a
short video message about my battle
with the illness um using subtitles and
a robot stephen hawking voice
and by the way that video did like way
better than any actual full show that we
do which is a little bit depressing but
at least it made it worth the effort
because you have no idea um the physical
pain but also shame i had to endure
to bring you that video i mean i had to
come here to this place unable to speak
and i was literally discriminated
against and mocked for my disability
this is true
my own producer sean kept saying things
to me that he knew would annoy me but i
couldn't respond to he was slandering
beekeepers in my presence
couldn't say anything
couldn't hit him because that would be
an hr violation not to mention a hate
crime
and then i mean it just even our makeup
artist cherokee was she joined in she
said what's the matter cat got your
tongue i'm like
what what is this i'm actually
disabled what if i was blind
what what if i i swear if i came in here
blind there'd be people like sticking
their legs out and tripping me laughing
stealing my walking cane
hey blindy who turned the lights out hey
blind man
that's the ableism we're talking about i
could probably sue at this point and the
whole i would own the whole company
but owning it is too much responsibility
so i'd rather just complain that's
really more my speed anyway let's read
some of the comments from the sweet baby
gang on that video because they were
much more supportive of my plight
than anyone in this building was i can
tell you that
so salvis says i don't even have words
for how inspiring this was speechless
emily says i too have survived
laryngitis twice in one year actually
while deployed truly harrowing i was
mocked and ridiculed called minnie mouse
likened to the mice of cinderella a lot
of mice references until now i've not
had the courage to tell my tale thank
you matt walsh for inspiring me to speak
my truth sarah says as a recent
laryngitis survivor myself this video
made me feel seen i've always been so
oppressed for it as people didn't change
the way they lived their lives to cater
to the fact that i had no voice i mean
how hard is it to start writing
everything down on pen and paper so i'm
not so marginalized magic robot says our
hearts are with you mr walsh you are so
brave thank god there's finally someone
to speak for the silent struggle
dan says your emotional labor is seen
and heard matt never stop fighting the
vocal oppression
sour sweet tooth says uh matt seems to
forget that he has a form of
communication even more powerful than
his voice at his disposal dance he's
proven his ability to communicate
complex ideas and opinions through
interpretive dance so there's little
reason for episodes to be canceled this
week his opening monologue the five
headlines responses to comments and even
the daily cancellation could all be done
effectively dare i say masterfully
through dance routines and the sweet
babies would witness and understand okay
we were on a good roll with all the
supportive comments and because this is
all you're supposed to do when someone
is going through something and and
they're disabled
um all you're supposed to do is tell
them that they're a hero
and that what they're going through is
the worst thing anyone has ever
experienced
what you don't do is you don't give
advice
or tell me that i should dance for you
like some sort of wind-up monkey
dancing for your amusement
is that what you think of the voice
depleted community
uh why mill says matt what's the status
on the walrus did you uh come back to
your studio after your week of desperate
illness to find it waiting for you that
would be nice wouldn't it that'd be a
nice thing for someone i've thought
about
after what i went through
for that entire week
and all of the abuse it could have all
gone away if i just walked in here and
seen my walrus just sitting there
waiting for me
it's still not here
and i haven't rest i'm not gonna rest
about that i will i will track that
walrus down
i will i will find the walrus
are you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
see masculinity as toxic and think you
should teach your daughter to shave her
beard there's a better way jeremy's
razors are 100 real and 100 woke free
the premium
matte tungsten handle has more heft than
the left the razor head pivots without
caving and has six blades that are
sharper than truth
i'm just delivering this really well i
think those other razor companies keep
virtue signaling to the tonitarian left
and using money to do it but you don't
have to let them when you buy jeremy's
razors you aren't just making jeremy
richard you're making the woke left
poorer which is more important 75 000
people have already made the switch
visit i hate harrys.com to get your
founder series shave kit today that's i
hate harrys.com jeremy's razors shut up
and shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
vice president kamala harris is known
for sputtering and babbling
indecipherably like a very large infant
but amid her stammerings
she'll sometimes say things which
warrant further consideration not
because they're intelligent but because
they're especially stupid and harmful
and usually malevolent she manages to
sneak in these sorts of toxic morsels
unnoticed at times because her critics
are too stunned by the general inanity
of her comments to bother parsing
through the finer details
i think this happened this weekend when
another classic camillaism went viral
here she is speaking at something called
the oakland generation fund event listen
to what she says
so when we talk about equality
well that's a good
goal
but let us not presume that because
everyone should be treated equal that
they start out on equal footing
so equity as a concept says
recognize
that everyone has the same capacity but
in order for them to have equal
opportunity to reach that capacity
what we must pay attention to this issue
of equity
if we are to expect and allow people to
compete on equal footing
so equity says that we must pay
attention to the issue of equity a
perfectly circular and meaningless
statement
but buried within this mangled jumble of
words is a relatively accurate therefore
horrifying description
of as she says the concept of equity
and the concept of equity
really matters because though it's
malignant and insane we happen to live
in a society now formally structured
around it
so harris says that according to the
doctrine of equity
we all have the same capacity
but we don't end up in the same place or
achieve the same things because we don't
start in the same place
she says that equality is a nice goal
but you can't get there until first you
create equity
now when she says capacity it's clear
from context that she means potential
she's talking about reaching our full
capacity reaching our full potential
so we all have the same inherent
potential she says and if we don't all
arrive at the same finish line at the
same time it's because of a lack of
equity
that is a lack of equality at the
starting point
so she envisions a world where as long
as the starting line is the same for
everyone
everybody will run through the tape at
the exact same moment and hoist the
first place trophy all together in
unison because that's how races work
obviously right
i mean if everyone starts the same place
then like there's no reason why anyone
would get to the finish line first
well this of course is nonsense
we do not all have the same potential or
the same capacity uh it doesn't matter
where i started in life i was never
going to play basketball like lebron
james or the guitar like jimi hendrix
nor could i nor could i have enjoyed a
career similar to much less the same as
isaac newton or leonardo da vinci no
matter how level the playing field was
on the other end of it
you could take literally every
environmental advantage away from me you
could take all of my money and resources
reduce my life to rubble
and there's virtually zero chance that i
would end up living under a box on the
street shooting heroin from dirty
needles
my inherent potential for that fate is
about as low as my potential to become
an nba hall of famer
so
when we talk about potential or capacity
whichever word you choose
we're talking about what you're capable
of achieving
what you can build with your basic raw
material
your personality your strengths your
weaknesses your your intellect your
drive your physical stature your virtue
your vices everything
now environment may play a role in
forming some of this but there's no way
to level that playing field without
simply lobotomizing everybody and making
us all vegetables like joe biden if
camila doesn't have that in mind though
maybe she does i don't know then she
must believe that even in spite of the
differences in a person's intellect
personality ambition etc still we should
end up in the same place as if the raw
material means nothing
and that again is abject nonsense
but our country revolves around it
because that's what equity says
now it's not hard to see why the powers
that be find the equity myth so useful
first of all it gives them a pretense
for chopping down all the stocks that
are that have grown too tall they can
sort of keep everybody in check by
kneecapping anyone who enjoys too much
prosperity and as they go all tonya
harding on the successful ones they can
justify it by claiming that these people
only got to this point because of unfair
systemic advantages
not because they worked harder
certainly not because they're smarter or
better than anybody else that of course
is one of the most important equity
tenets by the way
differences in intelligence don't exist
or they don't matter
everybody is equally smart and equally
stupid
then by obsessing over equity people
become by design
resentful
and suspicious towards each other
rather than looking with admiration on
those who have achieved greater things
trying to learn from them like we should
do with the men on mount rushmore
seeking them out as mentors and coaches
which i guess you can't really do with
those men in particular because they're
dead but in general
rather than doing that instead the
equity-minded person hates the more
successful person
he feels an unjustifiable and irrational
sense of somehow having been robbed by
that
person he sees what other people have
and believes that he should have all the
same things and he would have them if
not for the mysterious invisible yet
somehow systemic roadblocks have been
put in his way
now all of this misfortune all of his
misfortunes and failures are are due to
the system he says
therefore
he must go to the system ironically to
the government for the solution to his
problems equity not only makes people
resentful and suspicious but also
most importantly dependent
the system created the inequities that
you allegedly suffer from so then only
the system can fix them
and here's the good news people like
camilla harris who've been in the system
and helping to run it for decades hold
the key to solving all the problems and
healing all of your trauma
just please don't stop for even a second
and ask why they never used the key if
they've had it this whole time
don't think critically about it
don't evaluate anything don't use your
brain
the whole point of equity is that you
shouldn't have to
just sit there slack-jawed and helpless
mouth a gape like a baby bird waiting
for mommy bird to come by and
regurgitate your daily rations
that is exactly how people like harris
want all of us to be
they want you to be angry sad bitter
resentful envious
and also totally
desperately dependent
and that is why camille harris is
cancelled for
the fifth time but i just can't camille
harris the entire concept of equity is
also today cancelled
and that is not it for us today some
exciting news actually we're adding a
new segment onto the show for
subscribers after the cancellation every
day we're gonna go to the mailbag and
answer longer questions give maybe get
some advice maybe um answer some
criticisms hopefully read some hate mail
on occasion to keep it fresh it'll be a
fun segment but you have to be a member
to watch it so click the link in the
description and we'll see you over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you